in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones Tyrion Lannister encounters the
mountain clansmen of the Vale savage
warriors who live as bandits and outlaws
in the mountains of the moon the
clansmen threatened to kill Tyrion at
first but he convinces them to fight for
him instead promising gold arms and the
Vale itself so the clansmen fight for
the Lannisters at the grain fork and in
the Kingswood they serve as guards for
Tyrion in King's Landing there's some
funny banter about feeding manhoods to
goats but by the start of storm they go
their separate ways some stay in the
Kingswood while others go home to the
Vale so the clansmen play only a minor
role in the story so far but there are
actually some really cool theories about
them one of which concerns timett son of
timett a chief of the burned men the
burned men are one of the clans that the
clansmen are divided into along with the
Stone crows the black ears and the moon
brothers but the burned man stand apart
from the others they're feared by the
other clans because they have this
custom of burning away parts of their
own bodies to prove their courage as a
sort of a coming-of-age manhood ritual
most men burn off a nipple or a finger
or an ear but timet put out his own left
eye and his fellows were so impressed
that they made him their chief we don't
learn much about timid as a person apart
from his ability to rip out a man's
throat barehanded but some fans believe
that he may be the rightful heir to the
Vale potentially the ruler of one of the
Seven Kingdoms so the Lord of the Vale
is currently Robert or Robin Arryn and
he's not expected to live much longer
because he's weak and sickly and because
he's being fed dangerously high amounts
of a drug called sweet sleep under the
orders of Littlefinger and Robert
doesn't have any children or siblings so
when he dies lordship of the Vale will
be inherited by someone in his extended
family in Faced Littlefinger explains
that since most of the errands are dead
or joined the faith the heir to the Vale
after Robert is Harold Harding Robert's
father's sister's daughter's son
Littlefinger plans to marry Sansa to
Harold in order to win power over both
the Vale and the north though in the
show Sansa is married to Ramsay Bolton
which is kind of a crazier plan anyway
Harald or Harry is believed to be the
heir to the
bail but Littlefinger mentions that one
of Harry's mother's older sisters was
carried off by the burned men if that
unnamed waynwood happened to have a
legitimate child with one of the burned
men that child would be the heir to the
Vale ahead of Harry fan speculate that
Timur the only named burned man in the
story is that child the rightful Lord of
the Vale after Robert admittedly we're
not given any evidence that this
waynwood woman ever had a son with the
burned men but it's certainly plausible
and it could make a lot of narrative
sense for the mountain clans to take
control of the veil because Tyrion
promises the veil to the Klansmen and we
are all told this cousin Lannister
always pays her debts Lannister always
pays his debts Lannister always pays his
debts and Tyrion is currently working
with Daenerys Targaryen who intends to
eventually invade Westeros many fans
believe that the Vale could be an
important location in Daenerys invasion
because of its huge mountaintop Castle
the IRA which is considered impregnable
unless you have dragons
Daenerys could fly right up there on
drag on so if Daenerys does invade the
Vale it would make a lot of sense to
used here in relationship with the
mountain clans to help take it
in fact Tyrion has already mentioned a
plan to use the clans against the Vale
also we're told that the clansmen
especially timid and the burned man have
become bolder and more powerful since
returning from King's Landing so there's
little doubt that be keen for an attack
so the pace is a role here for Tyrion to
use the clansmen against the Vale which
could set the stage for timet to claim
his rightful place as ruler of the Vale
of course there are still big problems
with the idea firstly Tim it wouldn't be
considered a legitimate heir unless his
father and the waynwood woman were
married and we don't know if the
clansmen even practice marriage it is
possible for a king or queen to
legitimized him it though technically an
already legitimate son like Harry would
still come first so Harry might have to
die for Tim it to legitimately be the
heir even if all that happens it's very
hard to imagine the Lords of the Vale
accepting as savage clansmen as their
ruler it could maybe be forced on them
whether they like it or not but it's
hard to see that working out in the long
finally we don't know if anyone in
Westeros knows about Tim it's possible
parentage and if they did how could they
prove it maybe Tim its mother is still
alive living among the mountain Klansmen
perhaps she could attest to Tim its
parentage the bottom line is that it's
totally possible that timett son of
timett or maybe some other unnamed burn
man is a descendent of the errands
whether he'll ever be recognized as a
legitimate heir to the Vale is less
likely so maybe this will remain a
little Easter Egg for the readers either
way it does seem likely that Tyrion will
use the clansmen against the Vale and
Tim it will presumably be a part of that
so at the very least we'll probably get
to see our favorite burned man feeding
manhoods to goats before the story is
done thanks for watching if you'd like
to read some further discussion of this
theory there are links in the
description to some relevant reddit and
Westeros silk threads this video was
made possible with the support of
patrons on patreon including Karen
grants from Alexander Del Toro's
Kingslayer Jamie Jason gray jr. a Alec
CDs Teresa revelry Lucas long a negative
maker rougarou Phillippe don't Google me
Podrick Targaryen Prometheus 133 for
thew Ciroc looter I wondered while
shaved Kitty nitros Atkins Nagi to wheat
man Stephen shot and colon BOTS thank
you all for your kind support